one of these watches is a vintage Rolex
Submariner estimated to be worth up to
$30,000 the other a total knockoff with
replicas steadily improving in quality
and detail it can be difficult to tell
the difference so we headed to luxury
consignment shop the real real to meet
with one of its authenticity experts and
learn some tips on how the average
shopper can spot a knockoff remember
your training
Lafe has gathered five pairs of luxury
watches one is real and one is replica
and I'm gonna see how well I do telling
them apart so by the end I'll be able to
hopefully have some tips to authenticate
like a pro how do you think what I do I
think you're gonna test how good your
eyes are and your attention to details
but I think you come out on top all
right let's go all right the first thing
we're gonna do is we're gonna kick you
out to handle the watch okay
what does that mean that means that we
have certain precautions that we use to
handle the watches so we leave any kind
of fingerprints or anything especially
we have to open the watches to
authenticate or just handle them in
general so the first thing we're gonna
do is we're gonna put on what are called
finger cots
[Music]
all right here we go
there you go and the next thing you need
is a little bit okay I already got mine
yes okay if you're gonna need this helps
support magnification over one eye while
you're manipulating things with both
hands okay um I have no idea how to
start even with this I think that's a
good way to start okay this wire is a
little bit loose so you can cross over
like that okay very cool Wow actually a
pretty good field of vision and you can
just pop that up on your forehead after
you're feel comfortable okay cool
I mean just with this I feel more
confident we're gonna dive right in
I've had to show you two watches these
are to blow big bangs they're a swiss
company much like the majority of the
watch that we sell on the real real
they're a very storied company the key
elements things that we're gonna look
for are in the fit and finish okay
but that is a finish especially in these
watches where they use so many unique
components yeah do you want to look at
the printing on the dial you want to
look at the numbers also in the bezel
they have these bezel screws you want to
look at the fit and finish with those
how crisp and clean everything is
alright it says Lu blow big bangs I'd
like that's a good sign for this one
mm-hmm
it says titanium but it might just say
that maybe it's not actually titania I'm
gonna feel and feel the weight to see if
it if it feels like I'm titanium I guess
I have no idea alright cool so but I
just need to put it on right be the
third wear is a big part of it too okay
cool I think that's my biggest takeaways
it is also gonna let you figure that
alright yes great alright I feel like I
know some things about this was okay
like I'm gonna inspect the other one to
see if I'm right alright switch pin
switch is I automatically affect this
one's a little bit heavier it's a little
bit larger okay it's not a song yeah
right I can already tell that the screws
on this one are a little bit cleaner so
yeah that might mean something where I
might add the numbers are pretty slim
this one to feel like I learned nothing
from that I'm just gonna put it on and
see how I feel okay I really like how
this one feels I think I know which one
is real okay one is fake so after
examining both blows I think the real
one is this one right here with the
black rim a little bit heavier slightly
nicer screws so I feel like I'm gonna
say this one okay that is your guess
okay and am i right well no oh you're
wrong it is a super fake so okay I will
give you super credit for looking at the
details that you've added Wow but not
being familiar with what it should be
yeah that's where they get you okay cool
starting off we're gonna look at the
dial printing okay and you can see that
who blow on this one is raised
it's very Sheen it has a nice fit and
finish to it okay also all of the
numbers are very tight and clean yeah
the printing of you blow on the dial is
one of the bigger tells yeah because
it's not very finished it's not raised
like this moves what we would expect to
see all right so I definitely feel the
first round but I feel like I can do it
from this next round so what do we have
for round 2 we have the Omega C masters
okay we'll take them off the cuff
because these we want to inspect every
angle all the fine details as well as
the case back these have a special
engraving this has a hippocampus on the
back it's pretty well crafted from what
I can see all right I'm gonna try it on
just see how it fits feels good not too
heavy not too light and me the next one
sir okay this one is a slightly
different model okay but that's half the
fun I think this is a big deal
this one the hippocampus and all the
things are happening on the back are
sort of raised and they're like engraved
I feel like might be an important sign
all right so this is what I'm gonna do
for this one because I didn't do it for
the last one I'm gonna look at them both
together which I feel like is really
gonna help me see things I'm gonna make
a guess an educated guess mm-hmm I'm
gonna say that
this one is the real watch okay am i
right
you were not me were fooled again one of
the things that you didn't do okay well
you didn't check the bezel this bezel
doesn't turn okay that one oh and on all
dive watches that have dive bezels
they'll have a unidirectional bezel
medians and one to right yeah so that's
a pretty big toe but again you're
dealing with a super fake Wow you did
admirable yeah you know they're they're
very hard to tell apart thanks for
trying to make me feel better this is
not going well but I feel I still feel
confident for some reason I can still
meet the goal I said I'm getting three
of these right so let's just hop into
the next one what do we have next we're
gonna look at car da Santos 100's wow
these are beautiful these are beautiful
watches these are one of the best
sellers that we have these are meant to
be worn okay I mean the artistry is
there and Cartier does it probably
better than anybody else okay their
designs are fabulous
but these are functional micro machines
we'll have a look at these all right and
again we're looking at fit and finish
[Music]
I'm gonna put this one on the table for
now and take a look at this other one
here okay
now this one I'm already seeing
somewhere which is perhaps a tat sign
someone probably really wore this really
really sturdy I'm gonna take a look at
this one more time side outside now I
will tell you about one other thing that
Cartier does they have a secret
signature on the dial on the dial yeah
so I'm gonna ask you to find the secret
say it'll say Cartier okay and it's
hidden it's not obviously right the big
Cartier right out of the dial under the
12 but there's another hidden Cartier
signature oh I found it it's like I
guess it's between the six and the next
number over here is that it yes all
right so what I noticed also looking at
this is that they're like little pieces
surrounding the diamonds that are not
the same like they don't always go
around the diamond there's kind of it's
kind of messy on the side here mm-hmm so
I feel like a real Cartier watch would
have gotten that right so here we go
this is a very important round out of
these two watches I do believe this is
the real watch you got all right yeah so
I got that one right now we're on to the
fourth one we're nearing the finish line
what do we have here okay so what we
have here are two vintage Rolex
Submariner
these sold for less than $1,000 when
they were new okay but now the watches
I'm gonna hand you retailing for about
$30,000 because they are so collectible
what are the first things that you're
noticing notice things some similarities
just inside under the dome but also
interesting some differences so I just
think I think it is a closer look
absolutely all right definitely dive
into these I'll start with this one
[Music]
the logo looks right it's called the
cornet the cornet yes given this era of
wash we expect that the tritium is not
going to go anymore okay
the half-life is expired is no longer a
luminous material okay so if you do a
quick test of the watch you just block
out all the light you shouldn't see any
glow
okay this one is actually glowing okay
and say you don't want to see it glowing
is what you're saying we would not
expect to see that they stopped using
tritium on the dials in about 1995 okay
okay so we're getting a reactor
definitely lack light yeah okay cool
check this one no no reaction okay cool
I think I know okay one is the real and
which one is the fake I wish I said the
real real I think may I know the real
one in it left this one you are correct
redemption is right there I will say you
gave me a lot of because you're feeling
so confident and you're coming so well
we're gonna make this a little bit
harder for you okay it's gonna be one
watch all right I'm not gonna tell you
anything about it you're gonna have to
use everything that you've learned all
my skills all your skills this is it
this is the moment you move from student
to master all right this is it
so this is a car d8 Pasha okay and this
is more like real life because yes when
someone brings you a watch you don't
really have another one necessarily to
look at it next to exactly this is
exactly how we experience okay all right
here we go I'm going in cardio number
two watch number five remember your
training everything seems very sturdy
I'm gonna open this up it has a history
class okay and this is what they call
the butterfly class because it opened on
two sides
no no way is your finger under one side
and pop oh wow
is it hops up on both okay cool opens
like a butterfly's wings that is a
pretty cool design elements after
careful consideration I do believe that
this watch is in fact real
are you sure and I really like do me
fake yeah the tough one this is this is
why you're the master and this is the
reason why I am the big tell is if we
flip this over all right the movement is
not what we would expect to see haha
finish Wow well thank you so much I'll
expect you at a 9:30 unload right yes
exactly that will get you work for less
than 2
you